all righty okay would you like to share
what your sad mr. Jose like dick pics
[Laughter]
not ones that people sent him he googled
them okay yeah alright I got I got
tricked by my friends so as a as as a
thank you for that I sent a man stuck in
a solid dick just to our business
partners to our business partners in
Northern California a man by the name of
Thomas Beck told he gets into a argument
an argument with a guy named Leslie
James lesson Leslie's the last name
there's all there's also guys in my crew
Leslie Ashley Casey ugh like girl name
we have C could be you guys yeah yeah
I've heard a Leslie I heard it more back
then and Jess Jess
yeah just can be a guy named to I what
about Jesse Oh Jesse hi Jess you don't
up Jess I may be short for Jesse
yeah Jesse but then Jessica that's crazy
oh yeah I used to hate my own name
because I liked it in the 90s I don't
know why there was a boom and the name
Casey and it always happened to be at
all yeah but ninya cases on hotels to
held it down like dude
Casey Jones man I've ever met a female
Marcus no all right so this guy named
Thomas and James get into an argument
and then Thomas gets really mad gets in
his car and literally runs over James
knocking the man unconscious and leaves
him for dead
please I think Joe still laughing about
the penis I know he
I didn't hear the comedy fire you gotta
stand up and just like shake it off can
we put that picture in this video you'll
see the tip though that's about the boy
it's not the point I mean that's the
point you know like girls on Instagram
they can show whatever as long as it's
like this so I thought for guys you
could show the whole shaft just not the
tip cuz it at least they could enjoy it
with that song every blow job scene is
alright alright so yeah so this guy hits
and runs to get another guy reason for
dead and this happens this happens at
4:30 4:30 p.m.
right outside the city of Stockton
California that's what happened Stockton
is a pretty tough town just look at hit
and run yep and don't jog in Stockton at
night exactly so now police are looking
for a man by the name of Thomas decked
old and looking for him under I guess
attempted murder assault with a deadly
weapon battery with the serious injury
and felony hit-and-run
now three hours later at 7:30 p.m. the
deputies are tipped off that they found
Bechtold
and he's right back at the same
intersection that 7:30 p.m.
deputies get tipped off they found the
dude and this dude is at the
intersection where the assaults happened
and he is now tied with his hands behind
his back to a telephone pole bruised and
scraped what the cop
like people someone found it to come
back yeah they think people found him
like that and the cops came up it came
came in and arrested him
somehow there was some sort of like
vigilante justice [ __ ] Batman came in
and says he's just an [ __ ] in real
life and someone else just did that and
that bigger [ __ ] came in like us like
do they put it out to like the news and
animals looking or just coffee because
like it would have to be a vigil after
that to know that that yep I have to
take you back to this spot and I tie you
up leave you beat in a bloody it was a
spot it was the spot that he did a
hit-and-run same exact spot that the
hater how much longer three hours he
went he fled and police couldn't track
him down so if somebody nearby and
they're like I'm gonna get this bucket
yeah unless they witnessed it and do
like oh my god that's what I'm thinking
three hours is too soon
yeah that's great and then the guy that
you hit couldn't bend the guy because he
was hit unconscious he was just out was
he dead I I mean it was enough for it to
be attempted murder this guy was pretty
like battery with serious injury so guys
that he hit that he hit with his car is
not the guy that took that this Thomas a
lot of drunk drivers they just freak out
and they do hit and runs yeah well they
these guys are arguing at first so what
the argument was no we do not know but I
was going through the comments and
people are like oh method argument
they're all mad I miss doctor so it's
like one guy yeah so it was two guys in
the car no you guys arguing one guy
jumps in the car and runs the other guy
oh yeah so this is proof that Batman
exists oh I wish that was like a
real-life Batman you would yeah the only
thing you wish look how happening it's
happening but I feel like if if it does
happen you have all other people that
are like I want to do that I want to be
a real-life superhero it kind like in
Batman what people wanted to take it in
their own hands and they're the ones
that are getting killed by the Joker
that was pretty funny who's the fat
Batman - oh yeah the hockey pants Batman
and this is Thomas this is the guy that
looks like a vampire I got beat up I bet
Batman does the purchase
he got beat up my blade dude look at
that movie - yeah he does it looks like
a villain man that's [ __ ] dog dude what
would happen if there was a real
vigilante now is actually taking out bad
guys I would love it will they have them
in Seattle have you seen those guys are
they actually beating up people cuz I've
heard if they're not beating up the
superhero all right and then they're
like helping old ladies cross the street
by doing my humanitarian work but like a
guy going at a rally [ __ ] [ __ ]
looking people up the stuff that you see
in the movies by happening in real life
yeah I'll be kind of cool yeah that's
like do the cops hate them
do they work with the FBI I feel like
they could it kind of like in Batman
it's like they're taking it to their own
hands
it's illegal because you're not law
enforcement you're doing a lot of stuff
and then with that it's like how are you
gonna like in real life they're gonna
find you quit what if it's a guy that
like they really can't take down right
and then so like I think a lot of cops
because you have a lot of cop friends
they they want justice but they know how
hard it is to get justice so for example
one of my buddies is a cop and like just
there's cartel operations up here all
the time and they say see if they have
evidence whatever and they take them in
the jail because of their connections
literally within two hours they post
bail and then and the bail could be like
a million dollars they think okay this
fool is never getting away
these cartel guys are now gone and
they're like what the [ __ ] it took us so
long a ver track down the safehouse
to get these guys these guys are gone
and they track them these guys already
back south of the border so for them if
they just died yeah or some unforeseen
reason then it's like justice was served
yes no because a lot of cops feel
helpless - whether they're like I want
to clean up the streets yeah but because
of the laws we have laws that protect
the criminal yeah it's so hard to
actually clean up the streets because
you have a lot of people also don't know
that there's a lot of border towns by
like Arizona and New Mexico and stuff I
have a friend who is a volunteer
policeman because the border towns are
so underfunded and they don't have
enough law enforcement to help out they
need help from outside cities and
communities right so he's a volunteer
policeman he goes there I think twice a
year to do some police work and he says
that these small towns they're kind of
controlled by the cartel because the
cartel will come through and they'll be
like hey we're gonna drive through your
town just to let you know that
we could either cause havoc here or we
could give trouble to the next town over
but we're just gonna use this as a way
to like go through and the cops have no
way of saying like knob because there's
not enough these guys have their
outgunned and outnumbered and that's
what people don't know about like some
of the small cities in the small towns
in the southwest and it's it's kind of
[ __ ] up for them because they just
kind of let these guys go through and he
says some of the cartel guys will just
boldly have massive guns just chillin in
the car but they probably wish there was
an ant man that can come and save the
town yeah intervene though the police
intervening then they start shooting the
citizens yeah cartel guys yeah so it's
like that's what they mean by trouble
it's like hey if you if you pull us over
like we'll start killing citizens that's
what happened with Chapo son so the
police finally caught him right buddy
got him coming out of like a restaurant
and stuff they arrested him and then the
ID brother no his son and then the
cartel came in and started a war with
the police with a police how to give up
and return his son have you seen that
they had a machine gun on a flatbed
truck yeah the footage is I was like
this is some terrorist [ __ ] that's some
like isis level [ __ ] tactics do they
come out and there's people that look
like Navy SEALs like dressed from head
to toe and they're like yes the cops are
here but the cops are the other way they
have like SWAT gear dude who would win
Isis versus Isis and the cartels know
each other is so tight I would love to
watch that why thank you I think with
Isis like you know in a field but like
in a real life now with the reason why
it's so hard on Middle East yeah you
don't know who is the batter does the
same [ __ ] with the cartel right class
you McCarthy in law enforcement alone
you don't know who in that police
department oh it's like a wharf man yeah
okay you took an even number of cartels
and an even number of
and then in a field if you have go for
it well you have a guy from the Middle
East that's like you don't know who's
doing what he doesn't have anything and
then all sudden he's like I'm a
sacrifice myself for the career good and
go that's true once powered by not by
money once powered by just like like
their religion or whatever Ivan the
religion it's the people above them that
force the religion that acts like it's
the religion but they're off another
level that they think that if they come
in suicide they'll do a win for the for
the group well then the cartel guys
they're just I'm trying to make a lot of
money and live the Rockstar lives or
it's just safer to be in that then
compared to being like a normal citizen
because then you're the one being
bullied though cuz how long we've been
in war with like the Middle East and
we're haven't been making any progress
where if we were in a war with like him
like Mexico or whatever tech school we
would take up to the cartel I feel like
the cartel can be taken out and Isis can
be taken out if you have jobs education
in a way for people to eat yeah I think
that's literally of the best way to take
them all out but also I feel like that
this is like wait I only believe in a
lot of conspiracy theories but in terms
of how the drug trade and stuff goes and
how the government profits off the drug
trade that they kind of need the cartel
in Mexico they like crime they need it
it's like war is a business for it oh I
don't think the Mexican government likes
it because they're not the Mexican with
America knew all the US government yeah
yeah yeah do you think Osama bin Laden
practices uh or a did he practice
Ramadan probably horse offal is in bacon
and drinking all day
I do bacon and Reagan you know he came
from a rich ass Saudi family right I did
yeah they're like family is tight with
the Bush family and they do business
together and Osama was like the runt of
the family not to rob but they're in the
black sheep of the family because all of
his family members are like
businesspeople they're more Western
they're like non Orthodox Muslim kind of
guys and then he was like well [ __ ]
y'all I'm gonna do the real stuff and
then he went to Afghanistan yeah
conspiracy quarter
Warner how you guys did it yeah yeah
something cc
[Music]